à la qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
déclaration du ministre des Affaires
étrangères c'est de la troisième guerre
mondiale pensait que c'est sérieux ou
pas non moi je pense déjà vous savez il
faut écouter toute cette déclarations
vous savez comment on sait quand les
ruissements et qu'ils ouvrent la bouche
il ment donc pas l'intérêt pourquoi on
écoute ces déclarations on sait déjà que
depuis le début ce sont des mensonges et
on passe du temps à écouter les
mensonges mais ça sert à rien c'est pas
constructif aujourd'hui ils ont répété
plusieurs fois cette menace nucléaire
ils ont répété depuis le début et on
voit elle est où qu'est-ce que se passe
tout à fait d'accord avec la dame parce
que si un russe il parle et qui ment
pourquoi on a peur alors pourquoi on a
peur de Poutine
que vous avez peur parce que vous
imaginez des choses qui n'existent pas
en modèle
c'est le problème du monde si possible
bah oui mais moi j'ai un peu peur parce
que sinon
n’êtes pas l'Ukraine et pourquoi on
n'attaque pas la Russie alors mais si le
monde entier est de le créer
le monde entier avait peur mais il faut
savoir que
le Mont d'Or il y en a qui ont toujours
peur peut-être entre vous quand vous par
exemple vous avez peur ou peut-être je
sais pas d'autres personnes ici
la peur ça vient c'est très personnel
c'est très subjectif la peur est liée à
vos propres histoires à votre
imagination l'histoire elle nous a
appris à être humble parce que en fait
nous a appris parce que c'est possible
vous avez vous n'avez pas encore vécu la
guerre
dans dans le monde et on sait que les
choses sont instables et qui peut se
passer tout peu déraper du bout d'un
moment à l'autre déraper mais sauf que
euh si on atteint toujours que ça dérape
ça va déraper mais vous voyez que vous
n'avez pas peur madame
il faut dire que c'est pas à commencer
il y a 2 mois il faut savoir que nous
prennent la guerre a commencé en 2008
mais ça n'a pas dérangé personne
pendant combien d'années bon on s'est
dit oui il y a une guerre en Ukraine et
même les Ukrainiens aussi se sont
habitués à vivre cette guerre comme
quelque chose de normal mais aujourd'hui
il faut savoir qu'on vit vraiment une
vraie révolution et je vais dire juste
je finis cette phrase par rapport ce
passage par rapport à la menace
nucléaire il faut savoir que aujourd'hui
ces trois derniers jours on vit un vrai
changement dans les mentalités surtout
des occidentaux on le remarque ça
commençait par la visite de blinken et
aussi de de secrétaire d'État militaire
j'ai oublié son son nom Olesen je crois
qui sont venus en Ukraine pour soutenir
il y a trois jours à ramstad il y avait
la réunion de 40 ministres des ministres
de 40 d'État ministres de défense donc
il a vraiment la première fois on a
parlé de la victoire
ukrainienne c'est la première chaque
fois qu'on a entendu ça avant tout le
monde est de l'Ukraine on parlait
toujours oui il faut aider l'Ukraine à
tenir ce pays brave on va envoyer
quelques armes quelques Stingers
quelques Jablines pour que les Ukraine
tienne et maintenant on dit non les
Ukrainiens vont gagner et les États-Unis
ont dit que l'Ukraine seulement va
gagner mais on va faire tout pour que le
crâne gagne et surtout deuxième chose
ils ont dit qu'on va surtout affaiblir
la Russie de telle manière que la Russie
ne se produit plus jamais ce genre de
choses
en train de vous contredire depuis que
les Américains sont venus monsieur
Poutine a dit est encore dans sa
conférence de presse aujourd'hui en cas
de problème nous avons l'arme nucléaire
nous pourrions l'utiliser
il faut pas écouter ce ah bon d'accord
ils ont testé un super missile avec 15
steaks nucléaires oui on a vu les images
vous avez vu les images mais c'est pas
le missile vous n'avez pas vu
l'économique
on peut pas dire n'importe quoi sur ce
type de alors d'abord Vladimir Poutine
aujourd'hui quand il s'est exprimé n'a
pas utilisé le terme nucléaire mais il a
parlé d'armes de certaines catégories
d'armes dont la Russie dispose la
réalité c'est que aujourd'hui comment la
Russie dispose d'armes de missiles dit
hypersonique ça c'est la la pointe de la
recherche en ce moment et les Russes et
les Chinois ont une longueur d'avance
là-dessus par rapport aux Américains et
par rapport aux Européens tous on est en
train de chercher dans ce domaine
j'explique ce que de ce type de missile
signifie c'est des missiles qui volent à
max 5 ça veut dire et qui sont
pilotables tout le long de leur
itinéraire ils peuvent faire 2000 ou
3000 km à partir du moment où vous le
vous lancez ce type de Miss les systèmes
de détection américain les plus
sophistiqués aujourd'hui les détectent
quand le missile est déjà dans sa cible
donc pour vous dire les Américains enfin
je répète les paroles d'un d'un colonel
de l'armée française qui m'a décrit ce
type d'arme il m'a dit c'est
l'équivalent des Indiens qui découvrent
les cowboys avec des fusils nous on est
dans la situation des Indiens exactement
voilà alors les Américains ont mis les
bouches non mais attendez on mis les
bouchées doubles ensuite le fameux
missile Sarma de le Satan 2 dont on
parle lui c'est un domicile comment
balistique intercontinental lui il peut
aller à plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
je dirais qu'il est voilà il est
spectaculaire il est aussi là aussi la
Russie dispose alors quand j'entends
monsieur Poutine moi ça me glace le sang
bien sûr je suis désolé c'est pas
quelque chose il faut pas rigoler
là-dessus ce langage là on l'a entendu
la dernière fois en octobre 1962 madame
c'était pendant la crise des missiles de
Cuba vous n'étiez pas né moi non plus
mais au moment où la planète s'est
retrouvée au bord de la guerre nucléaire
et à l'époque ce sont les Russes qui ont
reculé qui ont fini par reculer pour le
préciser donc voilà quand on entend ce
genre de discours par Serge d'abord qui
parle au troisième guerre mondiale
Vladimir Poutine qui parle de la
possibilité d'utiliser ces armes
sous-entendant les armes nucléaires
aussi la Russie c'est 4500 tête
nucléaires c'est la le numéro 1 en
mondial les Américains juste derrière et
nous on a à peine 300 pour vous donner
une idée un ordre de grandeur donc oui
attention aussi à l'idée que qu'ont émis
les Américains le secrétaire à la
Défense hier que l'Ukraine pourrait
gagner la guerre oui tout le monde
souhaite que l'Ukraine comment on
retrouve sa souveraineté néanmoins si
c'est pour après ne pas donner les
moyens ou abandonner l'Ukraine on a déjà
vu les Américains abandonner
l'Afghanistan à son sort donc attention
à ces promesses en l'air qu'on entend un
peu souvent et pour le moment il s'agit
de fournir des armes en tout cas il y a
eu ces promesses hier et il y a la
réponse de Poutine en direct aujourd'hui
le premier donc pour vous il y a de quoi
s'inquiéter oui il y a totalement parce
que il n'y a aucun aucune place à la
diplomatie en ce moment c'est à dire que
du côté américain vous avez fournitures
d'armes fournitures d'armes tous les
toutes les semaines vous entendez 800
millions etc etc les Allemands qui
fournissent leurs chars les Polonais qui
font enfin voilà on est en train d'armer
l'Ukraine voilà mais la question les
armes lourdes enfin oui enfin avec les
armures et vous avez les Britanniques
qui sont toujours encore comment qui
sont quand même les bons toutous des
américains et qui sont toujours une
longueur d'avance qui disent sinon aux
armes sont utilisées pour frapper le
territoire russe ça nous dérange pas ça
c'est une véritable une véritable source
d'escalade et et la question elle est là
jusqu'où on est prêt à aller alors si on
est prêt à aller jusqu'au dernier
ukrainien jusqu'à la mort du dernier
ukrainien le problème de ça c'est que si
on ne tient pas et si et que vont dire
les réponses que disent les Russes vous
êtes tellement je suis pas du tellement
rempli de la propagande c'est c'est
c'est c'est les
de ces de ces missiles supersoniques que
seul la Russie
et la Chine ont actuellement c'est ça
c'est inquiétant je voudrais juste dire
je sais pas moi je connais pas les
missile parce que personne n'a venu ici
peut-être mais non l'idée c'est que
regarder quand vous vous avez entendu
quand la guerre a commencé on disait mon
dieu la deuxième puissance militaire du
monde envahit ce pays on ne nous donnait
pas trois jours en trois jours on déjà
tout le monde on a proposé au Président
zelemski d'être évacué et on disait moi
j'étais sur les plateaux du premier jour
j'ai fait tous les généraux à la
retraite qui était les spécialistes
soi-disant de de l'action militaire tout
ce que je dis c'est c'est moi qui avait
raison je leur ai dit qu'il y avait ne
sera jamais pris il n'y a jamais eu
aucune étau qui resserait certes contre
qui hier autour de Kiev le rouleau comp
il est où ce rouleau compresseur qui
avait survécu son parti dans reculé
quand on va avec les armes lesquelles
ils sont sur l'Ukraine mais c'est même
ridicule parce que la deuxième puissance
mondiale ils sont arrivés avec les
cartes en papier ils n'ont même pas les
cartes ils n'ont pas les cartes SIM ils
sont pas connectés ils sont arrivés avec
ça ils sont arrivés avec les
talkie-walkies vous savez que les yeux
craignaient sont en train de capter
toutes les conversations de l'armée
russe tout est en libre accès si vous
comprenez le russe il y a pas mal de
traduction qui se font déjà on peut on
peut les écouter en direct quasiment
tout c'est à dire c'est la deuxième
puissance mondiale donc finalement alors
on se demande j'étais en bas oui avant
non mais avant ah vous êtes allés
on dit que la deuxième puissance
mondiale ok militaire mais quand on voit
ce qui se passe on s'est dit mais
comment est-ce possible mais comment
est-ce possible
quand même passé c'est un des pays les
plus grands et les plus puissants du
monde et vous dites ça avec une sorte de
désabolture comme si la Russie était bon
comment est-ce possible je réponds je
réponds à cette question
si c'est un pays qui est profondément
corrompu quand vous dites la corruption
la corruption les systémiques elle peut
pas être juste de ce côté là de ce
côté-là tout est corrompu donc l'armée
russe et les corrompus tous les budgets
sont détournés vous savez combien il y a
50 généraux qui sont arrêtés aujourd'hui
qui sont qui sont papa torturés j'en
sais rien ce confort avec lui mais bon
donc il y a déjà ça il faut savoir aussi
qu'ils ont donné 5 milliards d'euros de
dollars pardon pour créer un Ukraine la
cinquième colonne soi-disant qu'elle est
détruire l'Ukraine de l'intérieur pour
accueillir les libérateurs russes donc
tout l'argent est à Monaco à Courchevel
dans toutes les châteaux les bateaux
machin etc ils ont acheté les montres
suisses donc quand c'est détourné d'un
côté alors comment vous pouvez imaginer
quand on peut vérifier un char on peut
le mettre sur un champ de quelque part
de polygone on tiré pour voir si ça
marche l'arme nucléaire qui peut
vérifier pour moi tous les tout l'argent
qui était là-bas pour l'entretien tout
est détourné
quasiment la seule à le dire mais vous
savez que hier les ministres de la
défense ils ont évoqué ça aussi pour la
première fois public ils ont mis en
doute la qualité de préparatif
d'entretien de ces armes donc voilà on
s'est retrouvera avec les trucs qui sont
complètement rouillés pourris les fils
qui sont mangés par les rats je le
souhaite
quand vous avez entendu ce qui a dit à
la si vous pouvez lui dire non c'est pas
fait réagir parce que je pense qu'il
faut pas plaisanter avec Poutine même si
il a montré certaines faiblesses dans ce
conflit en effet les Américains ont
profite aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pour
essayer de pousser leur avantage parce
qu'ils ont compris que l'armée russe
n'était pas aussi redoutable qu'il
l'avait imaginé donc ça c'est c'est un
premier point ensuite les Russes sont en
train comme ils le font et comme ils
l'ont déjà fait pour les les deux
régions séparatistes du don-basse là
l'aublaste de de lougans et l'aublas de
denisque et la Crimée également
d'essayer finalement vous voyez ils sont
en train de constituer une sorte de
glacis tout autour et surtout ils ont
presque isolé la mer d'Azov il y a plus
que que Mario Paul qui résiste et ils
ont visiblement l'intention moi je suis
très inquiet pour la ville de DESA dans
laquelle j'étais il y a 15 jours qui
voilà vous regardez la zone à l'ouest de
dessin vous avez une région en rouge qui
s'appelle la Transnistrie à cette région
depuis 19 elle a fait sécession de la
Moldavie parce que s'il trouve un
général de l'armée rouge à l'époque et
qui est qui a fait lui allégeance à la
Russie donc c'est une zone où il y a 500
000 habitants qui est une zone prorus la
tentation évidemment de Poutine c'est de
relier toutes ces zones comment
russophone et donc d'englober au dessin
aujourd'hui dans cette région
séparatiste il y a eu des comment des
explosions une station de radio qui a
été visée les Russes disons c'est que
c'est des Ukrainiens qui ont fait du
sabotage etc ça fait monter l'attention
la Moldavie a décidé de mobiliser son
armée comment réunion d'urgence etc donc
là vous avez une tension et un risque de
contamination du conflit donc qui
déborde qui déborderait d'Ukraine donc
vraiment
par la photo des Russes
vous avez un accent maintenant
par la faute
[Rires]
si vous voulez l'idée ça serait de
relier toute de relier toute cette zone
et à partir du moment où la Russie aura
cookies toute cette zone et bien elle
possèdera tous les débouchés maritimes
de l'Ukraine et donc l'Ukraine n'aura
plus ses débouchés maritimes l'Ukraine
et le premier jour
de
de fin les vous êtes
partisans
s'il vous plaît est-ce que je voudrais
vous êtes toujours payé par RT ou pas
payé par RPS que j'ai fait par pour Le
Figaro Magazine voilà non mais juste
est-ce qu'il y a une possibilité que la
guerre donc ce soit une troisième guerre
mondiale et que la France soit touchée
militairement ça c'est la question c'est
la question qu'on se pose Régis Cyril
toucher militairement
la question française qu'à un moment il
peut avoir une troisième guerre mondiale
ce qui nous inquiète c'est pas
nécessaire
la France a des capacités de se défendre
embarquée dans des sous-marins
nucléaires qui sont aujourd'hui
sa capacité de riposte aujourd'hui la
France c'est là de sous-marins nucléaire
qui sont en permanence à la mer avec
cette tête atomique qui sont capables de
c'est des missiles
m513
mais pourquoi dans euh je pense qu'il y
a une idée de gradation il faut voir que
la question on est sur un conflit entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie aujourd'hui on
n'est pas dans un conflit les États-Unis
ne sont pas officiellement en guerre
contre la Russie donc les États-Unis et
la Russie on peut dire aujourd'hui de
plus en plus ce livre une guerre par
proxy par je dirais comment sur le sol
ukrainien mais ne sont pas
officiellement en guerre donc il peut y
avoir une escalade Poutine par exemple
peut très bien lancer une arme nucléaire
dans un endroit sur une région en terme
d'avertissement c'est possible et les
Américains peuvent riposter parce que
les Américains ont eux aussi des armes
écoutez travailler vos dossiers avant de
venir parce que moi je les ai bossés
voilà donc je vous explique la question
des armes on m'a appelé pour ça donc je
ne viens pas ne deviens pas grossier je
viens avec des arguments et je viens
avec des choses que je connais voilà
mais merci Madame est-ce que c'est une
question qu'on se pose oui alors est-ce
que je peux vous pouvez revenir la carte
de la guerre voilà voyez quand on monte
cette carte déjà la carte elle est
erronée parce que vous avez tout ça en
rouge mais en fait c'est pas du tout
comme ça c'est capillaire il faut
enlever tout le rouge il faut juste
montrer les c'est les voix qui sont
prises avec quelques localités il n'y a
pas le territoire n'est pas ni pris ni
tenue donc déjà ça on vous trompe quand
on montre ces cartes voyez les cartes
avec vous donc voilà pourquoi parti
il y a des zones qui sont conquises
il y a que les localités et les routes
en effet il y a des zones et il y a des
zones d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas
répertoriées sur cette carte tous les
Ukrainiens font des activités de
guérilla d'accord c'est une nouveauté
c'est à dire que les sur les zones
russes il y a de la résistance
ukrainienne qui s'est manifesté et qui a
causé déjà des pertes pour pour l'armée
russe donc
on rapporte les Russes qui sont
éliminées les soldats russes partout là
où il y a l'armée russe qui est
positionnée il y a des dizaines des
soldats russes qui sont tués la nuit
parce qu'il y a vraiment cette guérilla
qui est parce que la nuit c'est plus
facile vous savez si vous travaillez
votre dossier mieux vous savez que
[Applaudissements]